[Music]
survivor castaway Zeke Smith speaks out
after being outed as transgender by
fellow castaway Jeff Varner why haven't
you told anyone you're transgender
the worst had happened and the lights
got really bright and all sound faded
away and there was this primal instinct
in me which just said run but I knew it
couldn't run because I came to Survivor
to confront great challenges
I loved survivor and I was drawn to
apply for Survivor because of the
integrity and the storytelling we
started having conversations all the way
back in Fiji nine months ago about the
care with which this episode was going
to be handled by showing what happened
maybe it wouldn't happen to someone else
and something good could come up et
Skyped with Jeff to get his take earlier
in the day it was a last-minute
emotional decision I had not planned
that at all there's no way I could have
planned that I went to tribal and I'm
trying to show you three are being
deceived by these three so vote with me
and it was an argument I was making
that's what it was and that's where it
went and it went on for an hour and a
half and it was I barely met but it just
was awful i profoundly sorry
[Music]